Dans sa vie privée il avait le
droit. On parle beaucoup de qui
est une habitation. Ce que je
vois ce qu'il allait peut-être,r
de l'information sur le mode de
construction NETendances en
construction comment ça se
passe. La ville, il y a les
contrats, ça c'est un grand
public, ce service d'urbanisme,
les projets mais a tout le moins
il va savoir de quoi il parle.
- Oui, mais Annie situe Pamela
commetn la plate-forme M.
Coderre éléments qui font que ça
pourrait favoriser les gro
immobiliers et s'il est pr
des groupes immobiliers des
transferts de zonage et zonage
résidentiel au centre-vill
Ensuite la construction de 50
000 logements. Des terres de la
ville. 4000 loge
vite les permis réglementation
les conceptions etc. Ce sont
ensuite la réduction du vin, 20
% d'augmentation vendable et
familiale a 15. Est-ce qu'il est
légitime de se poser la question
s'il est trop près du corps
immobilier pour
travaillé pour ne pas prendre en
considération leurs intérêts?
- Non, ça c'est ssssssssss
parlez aussi de l'autre côté.
Valérie Plante veut avoir sur
2000 logements. Le même principe
20, 20,20. La vouloir cédait des
terrains municipaux et des
promoteurs immobiliers. Les
préceptes sont les mêmes. Moi,
l'avantage ne défend pas,
l'avane vois, c'e vois, c'e voit
que lorsque on va parler de
projets d'habitation, savoir de
quoi on parle. On a beau
dessiner de beaux plans sur
papier, des fois on ne peut
passer à côté. Il y a des choses
que vous avez d'autres ne sont
- Pourquoi n'a-t-il pas fait
simplement?
il savait que ça venait. Les dee
quatre ans. La tradition
américaine qui est arrivée de
ici depuis un bon bout de temps.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ne l'a
pas fait avant.
- Ça il y a juste lui qui doit
le savoir il a perdu des plumes
avec ça.- Est-- Est-- Est-- Estt
important sur les acteurs vous
pensait. Ce qui a été reprise
dans les années c'est une
proximité non institutionnelle.
Extraordinaire avec des hommes
d'affaires va passer des
projets. J'ai souvent évoqué
evene qu'au, il était proc
havé souvent ensemble. Question
se pose toute pensée est-ce que
si ça passe par des voies
officielles pour le contacter.
Est-ce que le lobby est
enregistré et lui sait se vanter
de ça. C'est vanté du fait que
quand
comment s'appelait la FIFA il me
répond : pourquoi parce que
c'est Denis. De proximité Tepper
au citoyen ordinaire ça fait
peur aux citoyens pas ordinaires
aux critiques de la situation.
- Voust être
parfois un avantage.
- Peut-être davantage mais
encore une fois ce n'est pas qui
tu es qui est important c'est
i ça sème
un autre doute. Ce n'est pas
blanc, ce n'est pas noir, mais
la décision me perturbe un petit
peu.
- Ce qui perturbe beaucoup de
monde, c'est le fait que le
grand patron a Montréal on n'en
a parlé aussi, Michael Rousseau
le patron de d'Air Canada, ils
ne veulent pas parler français.
La parler on a vu des images.
L'une, est-ce qu'il sait de quoi
il a mit les pieds?
- peut-être pas parce qu'il vit
en anglais au quotidien avec deu
monde entier déjà du conseil
d'administration qui vienne du
monde entier. Peut-être tu ne le
sais pas mais c'est une forme de
mépris. Ce qui ne disait que ce
gala n'est pas juste qu'il ne
parle pas en français employés,
puis d'ailleurs quand tu as un
précédent, les données sont
fournies, les rapports de
partout et de tout le monde sont
en anglais. Je ne dis aussce gaé
francophone. N'est pas intégré
du tout. Ne va pas au Théâtre-
Français ne fréquente pas
francophone. Si on va au Mexique
un mois plus conséquente aux
motoneiges et qu'on fréquente un
peu les gens on a envie de
communiquer avec eux. C'est lui
sait envie ne lui est pas venu
en 14 ans, ça ve
chose.
- Annie?
- I dont understand the
question.
Sérieusement, il dit qu'il est
tellement cubique n'a pas le
temps d'apprendre la langue. Il
aurait pu commencer avec un
- Les commentaires que bonjour
et merci la sobre de m'avoir
invité.
- Ce n'est pas une question de
temps c'est qui sont ses
interlocuteurs. Ce gars n'est
pas intégré à la Plateau Mont-rn
petit peu.
- On va se retrouver dimanche
soir. Pour cette grande soirée
électorale quelque secondechacus
montréalais ont quoi en tête
quand ils vont voter dimanche?
- Ils y en a qui ont la sécurité
et les finances, il naquit ont
l'aménagement et
l'environnement. Je pense que
tout le monde a repris le
logement en tête. Quelle est la
meille
logement?
- Déjà premièrement il faut
qu'il aille voter. La première
chose devrait faire d'aller
voter. Sécurité dans leur
quartier. Faut qu'il regarde ce
qui les touche les trois Prempeh
pour eux qui les touchent. Dans
les deux programmes électoraux,
456 de Monsieur Coderre. Il y en
a pour tout le monde. Mais il
faut vraiment que les gens
chercher plus de regarder aussi
les candidats dans leur
quartier, de regarder avec quiul
y a un problème on va appeler
pour ramasser les poubelles eta
changer notre vie?
- on ne reparle